in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Brandon
and Katie are with us hey guys how are
you great good where you guys live at
Tulsa Oklahoma fine fine well welcome to
Nashville we're glad you're here you're
here to do your debt-free scream yes
very good and how much do you how much
have you paid off thirty four thousand
seven hundred in eighteen months good
for you well done making what kind of
money during that time started off at
forty thousand and we're at 120 now way
to go you guys so tell me about your
journey how did this happen over the
last 18 months well for me it actually
happened and started a long time before
that about eight years ago when I met
Katie and decided I had to be get a
little bit more responsible if I wanted
to keep her so I loved it that's fun
very cool so what kind of debt was this
a lot of it was my student loans I had
about thirty thousand in student loans
and then we had a car so cool and how
long have you guys been married
alright so what happened eighteen months
ago that started this where you want to
hit the start button when I graduated
college okay I was like okay now we've
we've got a big change in income and
we've got a big opportunity to make a
big difference
oh cool cool and Brendan said okay let's
go yes yeah very cool
and so what was the hardest part of the
18 months the budget definitely our
biggest fight was the budget and
sticking to it was the hardest part okay
ongoing or just at the first or what
ongoing steel
okay I'm going steel okay what are the
fights about what are you fighting about
oh this just little things we don't
quite agree on just the the little I I
want to I wanted to pay it off faster
and more and live none at all in mocha
beans and rice okay so the level of
intensity yes okay that's a fair that's
a good argument okay that's a fair one
all right now it's done though yeah does
it feel
oh god I feel amazing just planning this
trip I mean it was just awesome that get
to come out here and just know that we
didn't have to worry about anything yeah
you can just pay for it yeah it was just
amazing
very cool what do you guys do for a
living I'm not plumber huh
and I work in Treasury I'm an oil
natural gas company oh great okay
excellent well well done you Ghana so
what advice do you have to people
listening that have $35,000 and doesn't
want to pay it off just I would say
stick to a budget and then when you make
extra money budget that too
I always would make more money and then
feel like I had more to spend okay and
then turn around and want to tighten up
the budget on her got this now for us I
think it was just a bigger picture and
we I mean I always joke about like man
that was a lot of work to pay off that
much money but at the end of the day I
think our work just started because that
was just the cleanup now we got a build
and there you go and do some things with
with our finances that most a lot of
people don't think about doing I know
you'll be able to change your whole life
and your family tree and other lives
yeah making this kind of money with no
payments it's got to feel great it's
amazing and we're excited to you know
get to tell our story to everybody in
cool just so how how much it's changed
us and helped our marriage and changed
our little boy I love it and how old is
he he's three and a half okay yeah
what's his name
Caden all right so his life has changed
yes cuz it's mom and dad cuz his mom and
dad decide to be grown ups I'm proud of
you guys well done thank you very well
done well congratulations you guys
alright Caden and Brandon and Katie from
Tulsa Oklahoma
$35,000 paid off in 18 months making 40
to 120 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
well done you guys man that's awesome
that's how it's done proud of you guys
that's fun hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show I want to write a
song I want to own my own business I
want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish